i'm trying to build
a human-sized bird's nest you see a few
years ago a great big story we made a
film about a guy who makes
human-sized buzz nests i'm jason fan and
i'm a nest builder
[Music]
it struck me that these nests would make
an incredible
office
my name's jacob another filmmaker with a
great big story
i'm the kind of guy that will go insane
if i'm not busy
don't have a project or any swords
challenge so you can imagine working
from home has me
bouncing off the walls
so i decided to see if i could be
inspired
by one of great big stories very own
characters
i've built around 50 nests all over the
country
some of the nests are as big as 100 000
pounds of wood
but what if something that impressive
could be built by someone
average average that's optimistic
[Music]
so i've got a week to build my bird's
nest office for my first meeting on
monday morning which is in
seven days i haven't got watch on
exactly seven days
to cut
[Music]
screw assemble no
gather and we useless
actually i've got quite a lot to do so
i guess i should probably get on with it
[Music]
people often say things are built with
blood sweat and tears
but so far i think it's just a hundred
percent sweat
don't zoom in
[Music]
oh god my fiance is always accusing me
of putting up walls
i think she meant it as a metaphor but
i'm a visual person
no no my poor wall
i'll fix it this is the back wall
[Music]
does it fit it it fits
yes
classic england
so how did today go really hot now
really wet
i should have built a roof i agree
i've got a roof
[Applause]
it's my man pretty cool man
okay i spent all day building this roof
and now we're going to attach it
there's map it's like a church
the church of jacob
[Music]
so happy
[Music]
well it's not raining
so i would say this is our window
of opportunity ah
[Music]
i think it fits oh no
it doesn't fit does it close
no we have a door
rain again wait it's waterproof
there we go i'm dry everyone we're dry
[Music]
so misty
shock horror is raining again
but this time it's raining heavy and
all day if i lose today
i don't know if i'll get it done on time
i really don't
[Music]
in panic mode a bit oh i lost all day
yesterday to rain
[Music]
and it's still raining but i've got to
get on now
because i am way behind
okay let's go
okay bird's nest time jason what do i do
the hardest part of building the nest is
really gathering all of the wood
i use a chainsaw to cut wood i wish i
had a chainsaw
end of day five and i'm so tired
so wet and so
far behind
today is going to be a good day
it should be the day the things just
start to come together
this is the length of timber that's
going to be on the outside of my office
it should look great but also
blend in with the bird's nest
and provide it with a good foundation
[Music]
i wanna go home
[Music]
well i've got one final day
to convert this into a jason fan
inspired
giant bird's nesty office
but i'm a bit broken
but i am excited to see how this will
turn out
because quite frankly it's anybody's
guess
i've seen this idea
in one of the birds nests and it looked
really cool
[Music]
so i'm going to give it a go
[Music]
the beginnings of some steps
all right jason what now i follow those
larger
sculptural shapes with smaller material
that i can weave in and around
[Music]
here we go this is it last log i am a
happy man
all i wanted was to build a brand new
fully functioning office in a single
week
and look there it is completely finished
absolutely ready for use nothing to be
done
yep this has gone exactly as planned
although i think
jason might have put a floor in this is
all finished
time to start my meeting well
that meeting did not go exactly as
planned
unfortunately great big story will be
closing down
and we're all unemployed
thank god i've got an office to be
unemployed in
but if you would like to hire me or hire
anyone that works for great big story
they are so good at what they do
and poured their heart and soul into
this so please check them out there's a
document in the description
with all their details social media is
the lot i guess i should say thank you
thank you to all of you who watched our
videos
commented liked shared we had so much
fun
making them and i hope you enjoyed them
and yes there is wine in this mug
if you like this video please follow me
on my crazy boat
and building adventures my youtube name
is jacob harrell
original hey um it'll be a load of fun
please come see me i'm going to be
really bored because i'm unemployed so
let's see what the hell i'm going to do
with my life